so thank you for staying for the last
session of the day it's been a very long
day for very serious talks so let me
introduce myself I am a Verena Guevara I
work in the Alan Turing Institute in
London which is the British National
Institute for data science and
artificial intelligence and I worked
there as a data scientist and that's
normal serious work but outside of that
I like to play with actual interesting
data
[Music]
[Music]
I'm pretty sure that's the name they are
going to use for a next movie so this is
the first time we have seen it so let's
talk about Star Wars who loved Star Wars
I certainly do
so when I was thinking so as a data
scientist what kind of data can I
actually analyze around Star Wars well
of course there are the movies but
that's kind of like movies you can't
really stick them into our or something
and do something cool with that and then
I realized that all movies have script
screenplays and you can actually get
them online and there are a couple of
websites that published scripts I'm not
sure what's the legal standing of them
well actually the scripts appeared are
usually very like very quickly after the
movie comes out I was actually really
disappointed that the script of the last
Jedi didn't appear there yet so my
analysis that doesn't include the
lightest film so I actually download the
script and if you look at a script it
has a very nice standardized form at all
scenes start with int or X meaning
interior or exterior then there is the
name of the scene there is some
description and then there are the
people speaking and their names are
always in both capitals in the center
that's pretty easy right and I thought
okay so what can I do with this well I
can parse the screen scenes I can get
the people talking in each scene and
then maybe I can even construct a social
network by looking at characters that
speak together in a scene and then I
would get social network of the whole
Star Wars universe sounds pretty easy
right so I looked at the script as they
were published online and they were
really nice HTML pre formatted blocks of
text with as I said the scenes in both
capitals here and names in both capitals
that's easy
so I wrote a parser for that I run it on
all the scripts and it didn't work
because obviously in data science 90% of
the work is data wrangling and 10% is
complaining about data wrangling
so let me complain a little I ran the my
program on all the scripts and for
example episode 3 of the prequels came
up with this script
and suddenly the names of the characters
were in both capitals again but they
were followed by a colon and then what
the characters were speaking so that's
not very helpful I wrote another parser
and had a set of regular expressions and
it didn't work either so I looked at
some of the names and for example here
the second character is not a free case
I it's a lowercase L
that's this scary guy by the way yeah so
I rewrote the parser again ran it again
with all of exceptions for the
characters that didn't quite fit in and
then oh I looked at the resulting
networks and something just wasn't right
because some of the crucial characters
were missing like r2d2 or Chewbacca okay
what's happening there like why did my
algorithm miss it so I looked into the
script and they come to name things like
r2 frantically beeps something that's
not very helpful and Chewbacca barks a
comment and Han says boy you said it
Chewie no you didn't
so I appreciate that the actors did
really good job interpreting these
scripts on the screen but for me as a
data scientist that's not very helpful
so I thought okay but I can't create a
social network of the Star Wars
characters and miss Chewbacca or r2d2 so
what I did I actually decided to
basically estimate how many times this
character would have spoken if they have
spoken in the script so I did that by
estimating okay how many times a
character is mentioned in a scene how
does it compare with the number of times
the character actually speaks in the
scene and I came up with some really
really complicated mathematics and turns
out basically characters are usually
mentioned two times as much as they
speak so that allowed me to basically
improve these characters that don't
speak explicitly into the scene by
mentioning by looking at how many times
they were mentioned so good I'm ready to
go except yeah well Chewbacca is happy
because he got into the social network
some characters didn't make it so if you
like the Ewoks they don't speak in the
scripts either but I just didn't have
enough patience just get all of them in
so I'm sorry and some characters messed
up my implementation again because if
you have seen episode 7 Star Wars Luke
Skywalker
looks very dramatic here they talk about
him a lot but he doesn't speak a single
word so he must have my algorithms again
but in the end I managed to get all the
characters oh I could ended up with a
lot of strings that I thought were
characters so I thought okay so what can
I actually do with this how can I
validate it something or someone is a
character in Star Wars
well my theorem is that there is an API
for everything similarly like in our
there is a package for everything there
is an API for everything so there is an
API for Star Wars
and if you go to swap Adagio you get a
Star Wars API okay I can use this to
validate my characters I looked at the
website they have very nice
documentation they have wrappers for the
API and things like our and cetera I
thought okay maybe I should want should
use just one of these but then where's
the fun in that and to be honest I
didn't do this stuff in our so all the
code is actually very boring if you look
at all the wrappers so I will actually
show you some of the code that I wrote
for it but it will be an F sharp which
is a functional programming language
it's statically typed and it has some
really really cool features for working
with data and I'll basically write part
of my phone provider that will give me
access to the API directly here if my
internet connection works so because F
sharp is a statically typed language
I will first create a type for my
rest-based API let's call it a person
because I would get information on
people and API returns a JSON so I would
create something called adjacent
provider and I would just give it the
URL of the API alright and I am
basically all set because right now I
can just type create a function to
getting all the information based on an
ID and the only thing I need to do is
load the correct URL and because F sharp
is a statically typed language with type
inference I have to change the ID to a
string and now let's get a person called
X
let's get the first person okay I
haven't done anything right now I
haven't run anything I just wrote some
code and now if I do X dot it
immediately tells me what's in the Jason
I didn't around anything what's happened
it's magic and the great thing is it
also tells me the types of things so for
example height is an integer you can see
it in the pop-up thing and gender is a
string I color is a string as well I
still haven't run anything I don't know
who this person is and if I look at the
name name is again a string that's
really cool the thing why you
I used F sharp for this is that it gives
me access to everything it interfers the
types I can write my code I can do
anything cool with that and I can earn
it afterwards and I'm sure it will work
because it looked at the Chasen format
and infrared everything so I basically
went on and created a wrapper for the
whole thing and it took me 67 lines most
of them are not very interesting
basically just calling the JSON type
provider and now I have all the cool
information about Star Wars characters
so that's actually around something
let's download information on all the
people and what appeared down there is
the F sharp ripple okay now I have
information on all the 87 characters
that are in the API and I can find out
all sorts of interesting information you
always wanted to know about Star Wars
characters like what's the most common
eye color and the most common eye color
among Star Wars characters is brown
because for example Han Solo has brown
eyes Yoda has brown eyes in case you
wondered the second most common is blue
and the third most common color is
yellow so Darth Vader has yellow eyes
I'm not sure how they managed to find
that that out
and I can also validate all sorts of
interesting information for example in
the original New Hope Star Wars Episode
four Luke Skywalker wants to rescue
Princess Leia and he dresses as a
stormtrooper and he rushes into her cell
and she's like aren't you a bit short
for a stormtrooper we can validate that
[Music]
so let's look at Luke Skywalker and Luke
Skywalker his height is 172 centimeters
I'm not sure how much that is in the
imperial units sorry I'm European and I
can look at the average height of a Star
Wars character not just on drew
processor II but the average height is
174 centimeters so yes Leia was right
Luke Skywalker is a bit short we
validated that all right so then I went
on and did a pull request and now a
sharp rapper is there on the suavi
website as well so now I had all the
scenes and all the characters extracted
from that I thought okay so what can I
do next with the data and then I saw a
very cool analysis online done by
polygraph where they looked at
screenplays and they extracted
characters and looked at their gender
and look at how much men speak in films
and how much for him and speak in films
it was a bit depressing because they
looked at Disney films and in most of
the fairy tales it's actually just male
characters speaking all the time so I
thought okay let's her look how it looks
for Star Wars and this is a graph from
starting from episode 1 to episode 7 and
these are all characters that speak in
at least two scenes that have explicit
name in the script and you can see that
it only improved a little in Episode
seven but in the original Star Wars like
83% of all the characters speaking were
males
it looks like space is for
men only and I'm sorry I just looked at
men versus everyone else so I grouped
women and robots and I'm not sure who
should I apologize to so then I had all
the data and the first thing that
everyone does when they have a data set
is to visualize that so finally let's
look at the whole Star Wars universe
open so this is a d3 visualization of
the Star Wars Network I can move it
around it's also fun for me to play with
so this is the network of the original
Star Wars movie episode for New Hope and
you can see that there are a couple of
major characters they have fairly strong
links between them and then there are a
couple of minor characters around this
little node that's not connected to
anyone is a character that doesn't speak
to anyone else in their scene which is
one of the resistance pilots that
appears they're only in a cockpit and
doesn't speak to anyone else so this is
how it compares to the first episode of
the prequels The Phantom Menace and you
can see oh that's that's a huge Network
because for this one there are major
characters they're fairly densely
connected but base why whoa what's
happening there and this is how it
compares to Episode seven you can see
that there are quite a lot of characters
but definitely less than in the Phantom
Menace
so can we quantify that actually how do
the movies differ in numbers and
basically my hidden goal was let's prove
that the prequels were rubbish
using data science so this is the size
of the networks just the number of
characters that appear there and as I
said these are characters that have
explicit names in the scripts so nothing
like a strong trooper but Han Solo
Chewbacca etc and they have to speak in
at least two scenes and you can see that
in episode one the number is the highest
than in the original trilogy which are
these three it's a bit smaller and then
Episode seven it jumps up again and to
make it even more explicit this is the
number of characters for a minute of
screen time so in the episode one of the
prequels there are almost one character
almost every three minutes that's way
too much so what can we do next I
decided to look at some Network
characteristics so the first one was
density if you have an example network
like this density basically just
compares the number of connections that
are in the network with the number of
connections that could be in the network
this is how we do it mathematically the
interpretation in terms of the story is
that Network is very dense that means
everyone is talking to everyone else if
it's very sparse
it means the characters just don't talk
to each other and this is how it looks
for the movies and again for the two
first movies and prequels they have the
lowest density that means they have way
too many characters that don't talk to
each other and then the density is
higher for all the subsequent episodes
and it was the highest for episode sakes
maybe because I discarded all the evokes
sorry again so then I decided to look at
their like local structure so I would
have a indicator called the clustering
coefficient so what it means is
basically looks at if your friends know
each other or not so this green guy in
the corner
he has three friends and two of them
don't know each other
and this guy has three friends again but
they do know each other so the
clustering coefficient is really
quantifies that you look at the number
of neighbors and how many of your
neighbors know each other and in terms
of the story if a network has a very low
clustering coefficient it means it
follows one character that talks to
other characters but these characters
don't talk to each other they don't know
each other they don't have any backstory
and if a network has a high question
coefficient that means and everyone
talks to everyone well I'm sure you can
imagine by now how it looks it's the
lowest for the prequels and then it goes
out in the other episodes so the
prequels were rubbish based on this as
well because there are just way too many
characters that don't talk to each other
and then in Episode seven it dropped
again so I can't quantify that for the
episode eight because I don't have the
screenplay yet and then I decided to
look at the most crucial question so who
is the most central in the Star Wars
universe so the most straightforward
measure is the degree where you
basically just look at the number of
neighbors so this guy is very central
because he knows six people and this guy
is less central because he knows only
three nodes so that's a very
straightforward thing and then I decided
to compare that with something called
betweenness and this measure tells you
how in between other characters someone
is so if I look at this guy and these
two other guys he's very crucial for
them because if they want to talk to
each other they have to go through the
green guy and if I take these two guys
the green guy is not that crucial for
them because they have other ways of
communicating as well so this basically
tells you how central a character is in
the story how much the character
compared which connects different
communities so this is how you compute
it mathematically that the crucial thing
is that you have to compute the shortest
paths between nodes and that's quite a
lot of work already
so the great thing in R is that there is
a package for everything so
I use the eye graft package and as I
said I was doing some of it in f-sharp
so basically I just called it from
f-sharp and we have a type provider for
that like the Jason type provider I was
showing you before
there is a type provider for our as well
so we just type our dots and you get
access to everything you have in your
our installation so that was easy and
this is how it looks for episode 7 so if
I just look at the degree the most
central character is Poe Dameron which
is one of the resistance pilots and then
you have all the other characters but
you can see that the main characters are
actually not there if you have seen
episode 7 if you haven't I'm sorry but
if you look at betweenness suddenly kylo
Ren is the second and Trey is the third
so this measure captures much more how a
character is crucial in the story how
the character connects different
communities so but PO is still the most
central character there he's celebrating
and now you might ask so who is the most
central of the whole network well before
episode 7 it was this guy obi-wan Kenobi
but then he died in episode 4 so he
probably can't continue being the most
central so when I actually included
episode 7 data Darth Vader still rules
the galaxy so as Jared mentioned
everyone wants to talk to me about Star
Wars and actually this is I did
normal sadistic PhD but this is my most
academically successful work to be
honest because I put all the networks in
adjacent format on my github with a
permissive Creative Commons license and
turns out people are using these
networks for education to teach people
network science as an example dataset
and then they have a higher headache
because they are trying to figure out
how to actually cite github or my blog
post in their academic papers and this
being
pretty successful and it was also
published in the actual paper magazine
in pro science which is a French version
of the Scientific American so I was
pretty excited about that
they sent me a paper copy and Wow
I did this while I was in Cambridge and
when I actually read it I don't speak
any French but I'm pretty sure this
doesn't say Cambridge so my takeaway
message for you is to like put your data
out because people will use them for
their own means they will get it wrong
but they will use them and then it was
useful for me as well because back then
I was doing cancer research and I was
reading a paper and I looked at some of
the figures there and they were trying
to predict oncogenes and tumor
suppressor genes and they were trying to
predict network between them and then
they had this figure there where they
claimed that tumor suppressors and
oncogenes have higher betweenness in
their networks and like betweenness I
know this from Star Wars so I think
there is a lot of value it's playing
with actual interpretable datasets
because sometimes you just run an
algorithm that you don't really
understand that while on your customer
database or on some gene database
something comes out and you don't really
understand the results but in case of
Star Wars you probably do so play with
interpretable data search please and if
you want to talk about Star Wars or
anything else just find me later or ping
me on Twitter or anything and made the
RB with you
you
you